call us what you will but we won't take
orders do you think we do this for fun
it's not like we take pleasure from
killing I don't want to work or die for
nothing
hello and welcome to hunt down to 101
the series that breaks down everyone and
everything in the Hunter hunter world
and today we are going to be diving into
the former patriarch of the world's most
famous assassin family Zeno zoldak Zeno
zoldak is a 67 year old assassin who's
best physically characterized by his
hunchback and foo men two moustache
however despite his withered appearance
Xena retains full control of his mental
capacities and has been shown to be a
brilliant tactician and is quite
quick-witted he is also well known for
his superbly calm persona and consistent
pragmatism in terms of his position
within the Zeltiq family Zeno is the
grandson of the somehow still alive Maha
zoldak and father of the current
patriarch silva zoldak however as zoldak
Xena was born into a life of pursuing
the family business having been trained
in the traditional Celtic art of
assassination and going on to become a
very notorious figure within the
modern-day world having led a superb
career in which Zeno asserts that he has
never once killed a person that he was
not paid to eliminate in fact despite
possessing the ability to kill without
hesitation Zeno goes to great lengths in
order to ensure that no collateral
damage occurs and in the event and his
actions do result in the injury of
civilians Zeno has showed a great sense
of remorse furthermore despite the fact
that he is an assassin generally a
position that one would not advertise
and would want to keep as secretive as
possible Zeno makes no effort to hide
his identity which was seen during a
meeting of assassins where they started
out by having everyone choose code names
and Zeno just chuckled as if it was some
sort of game and then went on to
blatantly state his name and then even
provided his business card to one of his
fellow assassins even promising a 30%
industry discount that is the kind of
confident Zeno has in his professional
skills which is a common trait among
Celtic family who essentially live and
operate in plain sight during his long
career Zeno has also developed several
key relationships and most notably
appears to be on good perhaps even
friendly terms with Isaac Natura
who despite looking roughly the same
ages Eno is actually well over a century
old and has known Zeno ever since he was
in me a baby
in fact as he grew up Zeno became one of
the rare people in this world to witness
the true power of network claiming that
he was the only man who had ever fought
his grandfather Maha
and lived in addition to this Zeno
himself stated that he and nasara have
been thrown into combat on a number of
occasions although whether or not these
were serious bounce triggered by an
assassination request or simply sparring
matches is unknown but whatever the case
Xena freely admits that his power does
not even begin to equal that of nattara
and that during his long career Metro
has always gotten the better of him in
general though Xena also has high regard
for the rest of the zoldak family
showing a particular faith in the talent
of his favorite grandson kilowatt and in
fact xenos confidence in kilowatt is
actually so great that he actively
supports the autonomy of his grandson
allowing him to go on his various
adventures were gone and showed
seemingly little concern for when killer
did finally remove ill amis controlling
needle from his brain although this
confidence does not necessarily extend
to the rest of the Tzadik family with me
Luke II in particular being an example
of a less than ideal assassin and Zeno
has described him as being both a genius
and an idiot
other than that xenos key point of
interaction within the series is with
his son silva whose abilities Xena trust
implicitly and whom often accompanies
him on particularly important contracts
such as during the york-new arc where
they were both hired by the tendons in
order to exterminate the Phantom troupe
but the primary engagement faced by Zeno
and Silva would be coming into contact
with the leader of the Phantom troupe
Crowell is foe which gave us a nice
glimpse of the true power of Zeno zoldak
Xena's mastery of the art forms of
assassination and nen have led him to
acquiring highly enviable and terrifying
level strength during the fight Xena was
shown to be capable superhuman speed and
power and even demonstrated a potential
superiority to crow lo in hand and
combat in the realm of nen specifically
Zeno is a transmuter which is the
traditional nen class bestowed upon
members of the zoldak family born with
white hair not only that buzina may
actually be one of if not the finest
transmuter introduced within the series
thus far his skill within this nen class
has led to a wide variety of hearts who
based on transmuting his aura to mimic
the physical properties of a dragon
which is capable of great defensive use
but it can also serve as transport with
Zeno literally being able to ride atop
his dragon shape Dora however aside from
his natural affinity Zeno also possesses
great skill in the area of a mission
being capable of producing an aura
construct such as his trademark dragon
that can remain in existence even when
they are several kilometres away from
him
Zeno skill and pure mission also allows
him to craft a blast of aura very
similar in nature to a dragon bull like
ki based attack which is
pretty phenomenal move in the world of
hunter hunter but in addition to that
after exerting such a large quantity of
aura Zeno didn't appear tied in the
slightest suggesting that he possesses a
gargantuan scale of aura reserves
another great indicator of Xena's
profound mastery of nen is the fact that
he can project his end to a radius of
100 meters and has even stated that if
he so desired he could extend that
radius to 300 meters although he did add
that doing so would get quite tiring
still for some comparison a general
master of Nan is expected to only be
able to produce an n that could cover a
50 meter radius and but all of this in
mind Xena was able to very effectively
combat CRO low in york-new City although
the leader of the Phantom troupe did
prove to be a formidable foe prompting
Zeno to put himself in a position to be
sacrificed in order to ensure crows
death however at the last second both
Zeno and krola was saved by a call from
illa me informing them that his
assassination of the 10 Mafia dons was
successful which nullified the contract
kill crawler
despite this krohler felt an inclination
to continue the skirmish towards ino
blatantly refused citing one of his most
important mantras that the zoldak family
neither kills nor risk survived for fun
a some form of compensation crawler at
the very least posed the question to
Zeno of which of them would win in a
one-on-one bout to it Zeno confidently
replied that of course he would although
he did at the caveat that if crowler
were truly trying to kill him then that
may well be a different story now this
is relevant because it goes to show
Xena's earned mastery of known combat as
he was able to very accurately deduce
the crawlers true intentions during the
battle had been to attempt to steal
Xena's abilities rather than to fight
seriously not only that but Zeno nee
instantaneously managed to figure out
the crawler required at least four or
five conditions in order to activate his
thievery power and as a result Dino was
hyper aware of crawlers minut actions
during the battle following this xenos
Hansen would once again be put on
display much much later in the series
during the final stages of the Chimera
ant arc after Isaac Metro contracted him
to assist the extermination squad with
Xena's role being to separate the Royal
Guards from the Chimera ant king
marihuana with minimal human casualties
this was accomplished by invading the
palace from above using dragon head and
then causing mass amounts of chaos by
invoking drag and dive a technique that
combines transmutation and emission to
split xenos dragon into hundreds of
smaller or a dragons resulting in a
shower of destruction raining upon the
target although despite the missions
all to be conducted with minimal human
casualties you know ideally no human
casualties
you know the casualty caused by dragon
dive would in fact be a human by the
name of Co McGee in fact when Zeno
encountered coma he being cradled in the
arms of the Chimera ant King he could do
nothing but stand and observe the scene
feeling that intruding upon this moment
a moment in which he was greatly
responsible for would result in a loss
of humanity within him and this is
another one of those rare situations in
which despite his not exactly empathetic
profession Zeno has shown that he holds
his own strong moral standards he was
not paid to kill Kaimuki which if not
for the healing abilities of the King's
Royal Guard he most certainly would have
and so he felt his action here is
something of a betrayal of not just his
industry but his own character despite
this the primary goal of dragon dive had
been to sow chaos amongst the palace
which proved to be highly successful
partially due to Kaimuki being injured
actually and Xena did successfully
separate the King from his gods although
not before catching a glimpse of the
Kings true power as in a split second of
distraction mara was able to casually
position himself right behind Xena and
network and in that moment it became
clear that the king was not a being that
Xena could ever hope to stand up to
despite his absurd power experience and
Shia mastery of the art of nen luckily
sino had not been contracted to fight
the king and the final phase of his job
was to transport natural and marijuana
to a battlefield far far away from
potential human casualties upon the back
of his men dragon with this finished
Xena briefly encountered his grandson
kilowatt who was part of the
extermination team knowing that he and
gone were headed for the same scene that
he had just laid his eyes upon Xena
simply stated that his job here was done
and to judge what was happening inside
for themselves however before being able
to leave Xena was challenged by another
chimera and by the name of Chi -
although Zenor
still grappling with the idea that he
may have killed an innocent bystander
for the first time in his long career as
well as the general fact that he does
not kill for fun declined
cheaters less than grand invitation in
the chimera ant would go on to be killed
in a single punch by Silva who had
arrived to come and pick Zeno up rather
interestingly Zeno did not show the same
level or in fact any remorse for the
loss of cheetahs life in this engagement
stating to Silva that he really did not
care whether he left him alive or not
and from here Xena presumably returned
to the zoldak estate and is
unfortunately not made any further
appearances in the series as
so mole fun facts about Xena Zeno is the
only character in the entire series who
has officially broken the fourth wall
and actually started talking to the
readers this occurred during the palace
invasion portion of the Chimera ant arc
when he began to vaguely explain the
past of issac Metro as well as his
abilities generally on his garb
Xena was seen wearing one of two
statements that read either a killer day
will never retire respectively proudly
portraying his philosophy in regards to
his profession and finally a truly
useless fact in hunter hunter the
nightmare of zoldak musical the role of
Xena was played by Musashi Nita who as
far as I can tell is best known for the
role of you guessed it
Xena's old ik in hunter hunter the
nightmare of zoldak musical but that
pretty much does it fizzy nur if you
enjoyed this video in the content this
channel produced in general and please
do consider donating to the new world
review patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan rain takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
who what or where you'd like to see
featured on the next hunter hunter 101
[Music]
what role do you think kilowatt and if
possible the rest of the Tzadik clan
will play in the upcoming up or for the
whole succession war Dark Continent
business I think we know who will be
following from the zoldak family and
it's not going to get killer he's just
off doing his own thing with a locker
and I really don't think he's going to
return but in the meantime we do have
illumi and color tow who are currently
members of the Phantom troupe who seem
poised to be heavily involved although I
highly doubt that things are going to
work out particularly well by either of
them
do you watch YuYu Hakusho because they
have the same creator yes I have seen
and read you Hakusho although it's not
because Takashi created them both
actually red YuYu Hakusho
ages before I got into Hunter hunter and
I thought it was a lot of fun even if it
was a bit more of you know a standard
Shonen to be fair though most series
that were being published in the early
90s have that feel about them and YuYu
Hakusho does have this nice nostalgic
charm about it as a result are you an
alien from Mars no no I am NOT I mean
alien from Jupiter actually they've come
to earth because it kind of sucks living
on a planet that doesn't really have a
solid surface also the anime on Jupiter
pure garbage absolute trash